hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay
we're headed to where really we're
headed to the mound to speak with speak
to the Greybeards at Iver stead okay and
someone said the signpost yeah I are
step this way this way Lydia hurry up
hurry up Lydia Lydia
no all right lit it Lydia Lydia come on
what the hell that's more like it
sprint lat last mile picking flowers on
the way cuz I'm a manly Argonian oh
pretty flowers yes all right
could be uh hoping it not too far to I
ever stand it buz probably like ten
bajillion miles I'm just gonna be
running through the mountain for a while
now
hello Lydia kind of teleported behind me
but that's okay more oh come on stamina
stamina flowers stay in there yeah okay
sprint again um oh I got places to be
things to do words to learn shouts to
scream all right Larry
I love a monster something this is just
a monotonous run or whatever lady are
you still there and I should just dress
you back up in your beautiful outfit
just for some entertainment on the way I
didn't want to say skanky although maybe
I don't know believe that tells other
people too Oh snow bears yummy more
berries I even gone I still go the right
way okay yeah I'm halfway there I'm
halfway there
sprint oh this is why I need it
why are you whoa whoa whoa who are you
it's not like my poaching is hurting
anyone so y'all can hardly eat every did
Kenny Oh what oh I should totally take
your horse take a look
who do you think you are I'll take a
look all right
that's a nice horse you have there feel
it steal the horse ah
that was mean after all that talk I said
about being Noble and always having good
good people do good things a screw it I
got a horse now one's gonna no one's
gonna care looks like a cow whatever big
ol horse but Brit for you who are you
who the hell are you hang on
greetings brother you look weary I have
something to help you relax
if you're interested
worked the finest school MA hahahahaha
Goomer ice of course ah snitch Oh can't
have you running to any guards now oh oh
you wanna fight blur guitar yah
don't Lydia go get him get him oh oh
honey he'll ha there we go
where my horse go it is my horse now woo
I'll take that totally illegal substance
um Oh Lydia could use these they're iron
but annoying she already has boots oh
where my horse go horsey horsey Oh what
horse there you are
come back here what do you think you're
doing haha big fat horse but you're a
little bit of a a little bit of a chunky
horse a chop but that's ok you do just
fine
come on here we gone down the mountain
down we go
and now sprint yeah a blazing speed go
Eddie go keep up now alright yes there
she is
I think I got a mod that makes followers
follow better go Lydia go keep Porton
walls Lydia take care of it and those
wolves are quick I even going the right
way
probably not I'm just falling the road
okay I just gotta follow the road till I
get to where I need to be ah ooh deer
moose whomp yeah I guess I can't exactly
kill you while I mounted can I swamp
swiggity boo oh my god
lip oh yeah not really it's pretty
stupid horse all right now once I get
into your horse you can't be running
away it's totally not acceptable okay
now got a nice horse where am I going
why am i doing i'ma going what am i
doing look at my horse my horse is
amazing here here not today
screw you guys I'm going up the air come
on Lydia we got work to do least I got a
horse last time I came up here I was on
um I was on foot and took forever
actually there probably some impassable
parts for horses but whatever I don't
care I'm running my horse up y'all can
suck not you all everyone in the game
who's trying to stop me on who that
would be but they're all trying to stop
me you know they are man this horse has
got stamina come on horse Blitzen turns
on a giant platter something bigger than
a dime insert something clever here more
wolves don't care
I'm on Lydia leave him alone we got we
got places to be
I'm getting main quests stuff done
raining raining up here
no way rain is a lie Fred
yeah this is much better this is much
better
ah like this we yeah
and I bet some of you're still shaking
your heads at the fact that this horse
was stolen it wasn't stolen it was won
in fair combat I was gonna let the guy
go but Lydia just came in and heard him
she's a cold-blooded killer and that's
why I like her
there's just a lot more damage than I
remember - but whatever
oh what's ooh I stroll hang on let me
fight this one I want to give it give
this one a taste now horsey where are
you going horsey yeah we got a troll
here real big monkey get it horsey get
it yeah yeah yeah joke top what horse
beuse come on horsey what are you aah
that hurt
what the hell like that
I don't I I forgot to get oh oh oh oh no
oh no oh no oh no Ron Ron ow
Ron I said Ron you [ __ ] that's that's
not run those walk that was wrong I was
wrong level level level up level of you
level please kill me kill me you [ __ ]
killed it kill me L give me heavy armor
do handed oh I don't know have you are
Murr I don't have anymore
points
our heavy armor was an Alexis cause
extra bleeding damage mm but I don't
think I'm gonna be using a battle ax
forever my ideal is you know the great
sword so I think I'll stick one in there
there's all tears off all sorts of other
stuff that I could do but for now I'll
stick with that Joe Lydia go oh my god
oh my god
who's Lydia ah screw it Lydia we're
going no I can take it dodge like a boss
dodge bang about er um Ally it hurt oh
oh oh
his skin where's my hit skin yeah I got
it in here somewhere to my favorites
menu head skin oh you gonna get now Oh
super healing oh [ __ ] ooh ah ah
not fair not fair I didn't have potions
of healing not fair I don't think it
would help me anyway
all right I don't even know where I last
saved all the way down
are you kidding me oh are you oh you
gotta be joking me okay fine go back up
the mountain deal with this crap oh not
even at the snowy part way back at the
bottom I should just run past it stupid
troll this horse this horse does not
like to obey me it still says steal
whenever I try to ride it so it's
obviously not loyal to me
horse was starting to attack the troll
but then it just left after I felt it
got hurt too much
whatever whatever go away ice wolf don't
care about you I don't care about
anything but myself and Lydia I suppose
yeah I care about Lydia oh right okay
what's bad save this time oh no wait I
still got a ways to go
damn it I'm so far away I just wanted to
get to the Greybeards why are they
throwing that I stroll at me whatever I
can kill a dragon but apparently not a
nice draw well that dragon I had a whole
bunch of other people to help me with
that but whatever you know what I mean
you know what I mean watch out guy
alright here we go this is this is about
where it is I think I'm not sure but I
think I think it is and I'm just gonna
blow right past it bah bah troll bah bah
Lydia do not stick around do not stick
around I need better I need to like
improve my armor and all sorts of stuff
like that I need to get my smithing up I
need a lot of stuff before I start you
know actually doing damage even my axe
isn't improved during chanted
and also I don't have any portions
that's that's bad that's probably real
that anyhoo gah I didn't remember it
being this far away but man oh man
okay I gotta get bean I gotta get be
getting to the end here oh here it is oh
thank you thank you all right it all the
way all the way up to the top okay
get out now horse you're just gonna run
away aren't you yeah you are you're
fatty
you're chubby chub Orson yeah whatever I
don't care it's just a dumb horse
Luna's one horse on a horse obviously
that horse is not mine at all old man
I'm Dragonborn up here uh-huh this
moment uh-huh in the turning of the age
I know what a dragon born means we will
show us Dragonborn let us taste of your
voice Wow where'd you come from
old man okay right in your face
boom sorry Lydia it's just you welcome
to high Hrothgar I don't like you boo
come on Lydia get out of the way but it
must on you know tell me dragon
buh-buh-bah have you come aster you know
my master we are here to guide you in
that pursuit just as he Revere's kids
have sought you are not the fern are the
first in many of the dragon blood since
akatosh first bestowed that gift upon
mortal kai ah whether you are the only
dragon born of this age that is not ours
to know why not you seem to rain off the
dragon cornice has been reviewed thus
far not just all I can say okay douche
alright I'm ready to learn let's get
this out but disciple interpret yeah
disciplines are you has already taken
the first steps towards object in your
voice fine to a thorn on a shout talk
give me this I am get it on with it
shout you speak in the language of
Dragon aha thus your dragon blood gives
you an inborn ability to learn our
hearts of power you mean like this yeah
three words of power as you master each
word yeah your shout will become
progressive whatever strong them ah
master I nos will now teach you role
yeah whatever a second word in
unrelenting force don't care just give
it to me means balance in the Dragon
tongue ah combine it with fus force to
focus your thumb more chakra fried wrong
me like death gather way Lydia all right
there we go burn it in there let me have
put on your appropriate garb for this
hang on you're in too much armor what
I don't care what a house guys carry
Jessie give me those back gimme gimme
you're gonna wear your nice clothes
no I took away your bum damn it can have
your poco hunting about there we go
no give that all right ah that's much
better Lydia it's low much better thank
you for dressing up nicely but learning
a word of power is only the first step
aha you must unlock its meaning through
constant practice in order to use it in
practice like that well that is how the
rest of us learn sharp by sharing
another beep as Dragonborn you can
absorb a slain dragon's life force and
knowledge direct ah huh as part of your
initiation master I not will allow you
to tap into his understanding oh well
ain't that handy Gibby
give your soul
much
uh-huh how about like this unrelenting
force shout to strike the targets as
they appear oh I can't hit you or
actually oh look it's not flickering Wow
actually I got a pause it here thank you
guys
whatever shut up I got a posit here
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye